I don't feel like my professional career
is what defines me or feel validation I
know I've been successful in it I'm very
proud of it but it's not where my
self-esteem sits you know it's not who I
think I am I think I am who I am in the
way that I interact with my friends and
family and so pretty grounded because
I'm aware of what's happening with me
but I don't feel that makes me any
better than anyone doesn't make me feel
like I'm special and deserve to be
treated differently and that's very
powerful because when things are not
going well I'm able to stay even killed
I'm really just in the middle if my
identity isn't attached to my
professional career when it's not going
well I'm frustrated I'm concerned I want
to make it better but it doesn't destroy
me inside